[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le point sur l'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition du
mercredi 8 janvier voici les titres
le parcours du 78e paris-nice dévoilé ce
matin la course au soleil partira pour
la onzième année consécutive des
yvelines une première étape le 8 mars à
plaisir le lendemain la compétition
cycliste s'élancera de la commune de
chevreuse plus courtes elles vont durer
quatre semaines contre six auparavant
les soldes d'hiver ont débuté ce
mercredi les consommateurs vont pouvoir
faire de bonnes affaires
mais seront ils au rendez vous nous vous
avons posé la question enfin la page
municipal 2020 il a été élu voici un an
après plusieurs mois de tensions à
coignières le maire sortant didier
fischer et candidat pour un nouveau
mandat il conduira la liste un élan
durable pour coignières avant de
développer ses titres l'hommage rendu ce
matin la policière municipale clarissa
jean-philippe une cérémonie s'est
déroulée à montrouge sur le lieu où elle
a été assassiné le 8 janvier 2015 dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
l'illinois ce treizième victime de la
série d'attentats terroristes qui a
touché charlie hebdo et l'hyper cacher
en janvier 2015 qui fera en tout et 17
morts clarissa jean-philippe habitait
carrières sous poissy le square au pied
de l'immeuble où elle résidait a été
rebaptisé à son nom il y a trois ans
[Musique]
c'est devenu une tradition pour les
yvelines le paris-nice et lancerait une
nouvelle fois du département pour cette
édition la course cycliste fera étape à
plaisir et chevreuse les détails de
michael lmi dos rond et de patrick
jacques de dixmude une 78e édition du
paris-nice une nouvelle fois au départ
du 78 la course au soleil s'élancera
depuis le département des yvelines pour
la onzième année consécutive lors de
chaque rendez vous les organisateurs
doivent se renouveler et créent de
nouveaux tracés objectif surprendre les
spectateurs depuis onze ans on voit
quand même pas mal de choses les trois
dernières années encore davantage de
choses quand les conditions
atmosphériques climatique s'y met avec
du vent on voit en convoi d'été bordure
on voit tout un tas de tout un tas de
choses donc c'est ça le vélo aujourd'hui
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve
nous organisateurs des terrains de jeux
et les yvelines nous offre la
possibilité donc de mettre en place ces
terrains
cette année la ville de plaisir a été
choisi comme terrain pour accueillir la
première étape de cette édition 2020 le
départ sera donné le dimanche 8 mars de
plus la commune
le peloton fera une boucle de 154 km à
travers les yvelines en passant par ben
montfort l'amaury ou encore
neauphle-le-château une satisfaction
pour plaisir qui a attendu de nombreuses
années avant d'être ville départ de
l'épreuve
ça nous ferons les chaque année mais
cette fois ci c'est vraiment bien
installé surtout que le village va être
dans le parc du château qui est un lieu
de rassemblement familial est un lieu de
rassemblement festif pour l'ensemble de
la ville
donc voilà on n'attendait que ça le
lendemain ses chevaux aux moins de 6000
habitants qui accueillera le départ de
la deuxième étape vers le loiret et des
stars internationales comme julian
alaphilippe ou égale bernal la commune
sera la 19e ville des yvelines à être
village départ de l'épreuve chevaux est
considéré par les spécialistes comme une
terre de cyclisme
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit qui est
particulièrement prisée des amateurs de
vélo
beaucoup de professionnels aussi qui
viennent faire leur pré saison et leur
mise en route en ce moment d'ailleurs
sur les routes de la vallée de chevreuse
donc c'est un endroit qui s'y prêtent
vraiment et que je pense les cyclistes
apprécié l'histoire d'amour entre les
yvelines et le paris nice n'est pas
prête de s'arrêter le partenariat qui
devait s'achever en 2021 devrait être
reconduit cette année pour quatre
nouvelles éditions supplémentaires
la période des promotions a commencé les
soldes d'hiver se déroulent jusqu'au 2
février les commerçants vont pouvoir
revendre à perte mais sur une période
plus courte désormais quatre semaines
contre six auparavant
l'objectif redynamiser cette opération
en perte de vitesse
allez vous y prendre part mathilde et
demi et jacques brun vous ont posé la
question on s'est dit tiens ça fait un
moment qu'on n'y a pas été le poignet
jours mêlant aujourd'hui on va y aller
peut-être que les affaires seront
meilleures je ne sais pas on verra bien
beaucoup d'opérations sont déjà faites
par les magasins à travers des ventes
privées
d'autres opérations commerciales
s'appuie d'intérêts particuliers c'est
moins 30 % donc j'attends un petit peu
j'entends voire une quinzaine de jours
le reste de l'année je n'achète pas
parce que je suis boursière et que
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé que j'ai déjà
fait une sorte de deux listes sur mon
téléphone de ce qui me faut donc c'est
pas du compulsif mais
premier jour je me dis qu'ils aient
encore des trucs dans les magasins
dépense tout pour la fête après
et un fait important pour acheter des
vêtements dans l'actualité aussi le 35e
jour de grève contre la réforme des
retraites demain jeudi une grande
mobilisation interprofessionnelle est
prévue à paris plusieurs écoles du
territoire pourrait être impactée par le
mouvement n'hésitez pas à vous
rapprocher à des différents services de
vos communes pour connaître les
dispositifs d'accueil mise en place du
côté des transports ce sera encore
compliqué pour cette journée de jeudi
sur la ligne u compte et un train toutes
les trente minutes aux heures de pointe
c'est en train par heure aux heures
creuses pour la ligne n
il y aura un train toutes les 15 minutes
à deux heures trente sur l'axé paris
montparnasse rambouillet aux heures
indiquées c'est peu ou prou la même
chose sur l'acsp les ir grignon enfin
pour les lignes de rer
le rer c comptez 1 train sur 3 côtés à
un train sur deux aux heures de pointe
et un train toutes les 30 minutes sur la
branche yvelines aux heures creuses et
c'est un train sur deux aux heures de
pointe pour le rer b un train sur trois
aux heures creuses
la suite des voeux des communes à leurs
habitants et hier mardi 7 et à
guyancourt 700 personnes ont assisté à
la cérémonie au pavillon waldeck
rousseau de guyancourt premier exercice
du genre pour françois morton élu en mai
dernier bilan de l'année 2019 remise de
récompenses aux habitants et
perspectives pour cette année son
interview au micro de michael et demi
d'euros je souhaite que cette année 2020
soit une année a terni t de solidarité
c'est important qu'on retrouve cette
notion de l'humain dans la ville et où
nous mettrons tout en oeuvre pour que ce
soit le cas pour ses premiers voeux
aussi en tant que maire de saint cyr
l'école sonia bros élu en février a fait
une tournée des quartiers lancement hier
mardi à l'hôtel de ville en 2019 le
nouveau quartier à charles renard a
continué de naître plusieurs rues ont
été inaugurés ainsi qu'une crèche
ouverte en septembre les libellules
autre grand projet le futur complexe
sportif pierre mazeaud avec la pose de
la première pierre
elle livraison prévue au premier
trimestre 2011 21 et pour 2020 la
nouvelle maison des associations elle
devrait être terminée elle les propos
recueillis par marie l'ania chisinau ça
a été une année qui a été riche en
événements puisqu'on a eu une saison
événementielle qui a été importante
on a eu la chance d'avoir de nouveaux
habitants qui ont répondu présent aux
événements de la ville que ce soit la
journée saint cyrienne la fête de la
ville et d'autres événements et donc on
se rend compte qu'on a de plus en plus
de personnes présentes aux événements et
c'est bien ça fait ça fait plaisir de
voir que chacun s'intéresse à ce qui se
passe dans sa ville une prochaine
cérémonie est prévue le 16 janvier dans
le quartier de l'epidaure 2020 est qui
et qui pourrait être la niche charnière
d'un artiste sommeil bonsoir on sera de
votre vrai nom julien me l'ont alors
vous avez rencontré à la résidence de
jeunes travailleurs marcel callo à
versailles où vous résidez actuellement
versailles où vous vous produirez ce
vendredi à partir de 20h30 3ème vendredi
du rock sur la scène de la salle marcel
tasse en cours avec deux autres groupes
avant de parler de vous et de votre
projet sommeil les vendredis du rock
c'est un tremplin c'est ça comment
comment ça fonctionne
ce tremplin en effet oui c'est un
tremplin qui met en scène la musique
rock mais pas que en fait et c'est un
tremplin qui existe depuis neuf ans déjà
qui a eu donc plusieurs occurrences et
il ya des groupes régionaux qui sont
vraiment un privilégié pour passer et
être promue sur cette scène mais
pourquoi ils participent et c'est pour
donner un bon à votre votre carrière
aussi parce que vous résidez versailles
a un côté local aussi qui joue
absolument c'est des conditions de jeu d
action de vraiment très très bien a
salle martial tassencourt et puis après
c'est vrai que c'est une visibilité une
exposition qui ne sont pas négligeables
et du coup je suis très content d'avoir
été sélectionnés pour cette pensée de ce
passage là ces passages alors pour se
faire une idée de vous de votre univers
je vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
cet extrait de votre premier single amis
attend du amis
c'est dans les sources
le taf
enduisez ma vie si je suspends ton
c'est ainsi pas
zhang
chat
[Musique]
je sors
extrait d'amis attend alors sommeil ce
titre parle de vos rêves abandonné de la
douleur du passé finalement il ya des
paroles mélancoliques mais sur une
mélodie entraînante c'est quoi votre
style du coup seulement et parce que
enfin mon style c'est un peu le
métissage je suis résident de martinique
à la base et c'est vrai que j'ai fait
des études de musicologie donc je
mélange un peu à la musique caribéenne
mes influences musique classique et gros
gros fan de rock aussi donc voilà je
mets là dedans un peu de rock indie le
britannique
c'est un gros mélange avec des
inspirations qui vont de jean jacques
goldman à la musique classique avec
maurice maurice ravel complètement jean
jacques goldman pour les textes voilà
qui est vraiment une référence laurent
voulzy et voilà jean ferrat tout ça
c'est des auteurs qui m'ont vraiment
beaucoup inspiré et qui continue
d'inspirer votre première rencontre avec
la musique à quand remonte elle qu'est
ce qui vous a fait voilà vous dire je
veux faire ma vie autour de la musique
la musique c'est quelque chose vous êtes
chez moi ça a commencé très tôt en fait
à 10 ans j'ai vraiment commencé en
autodidacte d'abord par les instruments
donc le piano la guitare et puis ben
finalement quand j'ai fait mes études de
musicologie
c'est là que j'ai eu vraiment un contact
avec la composition l'harmonie et tout
ce qui est bien le conservatoire et même
l'opéra jeunes de montpellier dans
lequel j'ai chanté dans les coeurs
pendant trois années
donc voilà tout ça c'était plein
d'expérience qui m'ont amené aujourd'hui
a lancé mon projet solo
et pour concrétiser ce projet justement
vous habitiez le sud de la france vous
êtes monté à paris les premières
semaines les premiers mois ont été
difficiles
c'est vrai que c'est vrai d'arriver sur
paris comme ça avec bon quelques
possibilités mais pas tout non plus
c'est vrai que ça a été un parcours
assez difficile au début
et qui sait vraiment stabilisé à mon
arrivée sur versailles ça a permis cette
intégration dans la résidence marcel
callo de stabiliser de vous stabiliser à
voir votre logement à loyer plutôt
dérisoire plutôt bas et de pouvoir vous
consacrer à votre musique ça c'est ça
d'être dans la région parisienne d'avoir
une stabilité au niveau du foyer et puis
voilà c'est vraiment mon dossier qui qui
a été qui a été poussé par parce par le
foyer marcel callo et c'est une chance
en fait et le fait d'échanger
les différents aussi résidence à créer
une émulation ça peut aussi plus à
l'inspiration dans complète motion
musique
ben justement je joue sur scène vendredi
avec les acquis et donc une des
résidentes du foyer aussi lé les
flûtistes et voilà c'est vrai que c'est
plein de rencontres et entre l'équipe
entre les résidents il ya il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses qui se passent votre
actualité pour terminer la sortie d'un
prochain titre la très prochainement et
aussi un ep qui devrait sortir en
février
c'est ça la ne paie qui va sortir très
bientôt je prépare le tournage de mon
deuxième clip aussi et voilà un album en
préparation aussi un album en
préparation ça ce sera un objectif de 7
années 2020 merci sommeil je rappelle
que vous êtes sur la scène vendredi dès
vendredi du rock justement à versailles
à la selle à la salle marcel tassencourt
votre actualité on la retrouve bien sûr
sur votre site internet et sur vos
différents réseaux sociaux merci
beaucoup aller retour en 2019 à présent
comme chaque jour cette semaine zoom sur
les événements qui ont fait l'année
passée ce soir embarquement dans notre
machine à remonter le temps direction
les mois de juillet à septembre avec
nicolas d'andry du changement au début
du mois de juillet à la tête de la
gendarmerie des yvelines une passation
de commandement dans la cour de la
préfecture du département
le colonel sylvain tortelier succède au
colonel loïc barras en poste depuis
trois ans sur le territoire commandé
dans ce magnifique département des
yvelines avec autant de vices diversité
autant de problématiques
ça rend le challenge défi d'autant plus
intéressant du changement ils n'en
veulent pas celui prévu pour réformer le
baccalauréat et le cursus scolaire au
lycée un programme contesté et préparé
par le gouvernement
certains professeurs des yvelines ont
poursuivi leur mobilisation pour
protester contre la réforme de cet
examen
cela à travers une grève des corrections
des copies dans les lycées du
département autres corps de métier autre
mouvement social les sapeurs pompiers
ont commencé une grève nationale
intersyndicale au début de l'été c'est
le cas dans les casernes yvelinoise
plusieurs revendications demande
d'effectifs et de moyens supplémentaires
et amélioration des conditions de
travail durant la période estivale les
pompiers yvelinois ont été plusieurs
fois sollicité notamment sur l' incendie
du siaap à achères le centre de
traitement des eaux usées a été touché
par un instant
10 le 3 juillet 2019 un site classé
seveso aucune victime humaine à déplorer
et le feu a été rapidement maîtrisé
néanmoins conséquence directe la scène a
connu un épisode de pollution trois
tonnes de poissons morts ont été
repêchés services de l'état élus locaux
associations et riverains s'organisent
autour de réunion pour lancer la
résolution du problème on gère
directement les 6 premiers kilomètres
qui sont la sortie déroger de la station
d'épuration et on considère que 90 % de
mortalité sur ces six kilomètres autre
incendie il s'est déclaré dans la soirée
du 31 juillet 2010 9 le toit des halles
du marché de maurepas s'est embrasé un
feu d'origine criminelle
un temps installé au square de la marche
les commerçants ont pu se réinstaller à
côté de la structure place riboud au
mois de septembre septembre sonne la
rentrée des classes pour plus de trois
cent cinq mille élèves yvelinois la
première rentrée scolaire pour le
nouveau directeur académique
antoine destrés les nouveautés de ce
début d'année scolaire la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme du baccalauréat pour les
élèves de première
avec notamment la fin des sections s es
et l
tous les lycées nous ont répondu
vendredi 20 même plus c'était plusieurs
jours que voilà les choses se passaient
bien
le gouvernement a aussi fait sa rentrée
avec cette priorité la lutte contre les
violences conjugales et les féminicides
des mesures ont été prises
un grenelle de trois mois a été lancé au
tour des associations et des services de
l'état
moi ce que j'ai retenu de ce grenelle
c'est prévention des violences
conjugales
la prise en charge des victimes et
finalement la sanction contre les
auteurs
le développement de la mobilité douce
poursuit à saint quentin en yvelines la
passerelle piétons cyclistes reliant
plaisir à elancourt a été inauguré une
infrastructure permettant de passer au
dessus de la nationale 12 et de longer
la rd 30
autre signe de ce développement le
lancement de v league au dans
l'agglomération ce service développé par
ile-de-france mobilité permet de louer
des vélos électriques pour 40 euros par
mois le vélo dans le coeur des yvelines
le 28 juillet les coureurs du tour de
france ont pris le départ de la dernière
étape à rambouillet le jeune colombien
et gagnent bernal maillot jaune sur le
dos a remporté cette édition à paris ses
supporters ont fait trembler les rues
rambo liten durant cette fin d'après
midi
l'émotion et la joie de toute une nation
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grands jours de m
autre émotion nationale la tristesse de
millions de français suite au décès du
cinquième président de la vème
république de 1995 à 2007 jacques chirac
c'était un le 26 septembre 2019 à l'âge
de 86 ans un homme politique de droite
fondateurs du rpr
il a été notamment à l'origine de
l'engagement en politique du président
du département des yvelines pierre
bédier le 30 septembre a été décrété
journée de deuil national journée des
obsèques de jacques chirac
plusieurs hommages lui ont été rendus à
travers le pays
[Musique]
et on parle des élections municipales
pour terminer ce journal d'abord avec
cette quatrième candidature connue à la
verrière une liste regroupant des
habitants la verrière citoyenne sera
conduite par gérard claude morfin ancien
élu dans la commune et ex-vice-président
de la ville nouvelle de saint quentin en
yvelines
il souhaite faire de la verrière une
ville innovante et rassembler avec une
priorité donnée au développement durable
et à la démocratie participative la
verrière où son candidat également le
conseiller municipal d'opposition
nicolas dainville l'actuel premier
adjoint et jean yves blé et la maire
sortante communiste nelly du cul qui
sera notre invité demain mon invité dans
cette édition c'est didier fischer
bonsoir maire sans étiquette de
coignières vous serez la tête de liste
d'un élan durable pourquoi hier on
rappelle le contexte vous avez été élu
pour la première fois en décembre 2018
lors d'une municipale partielle
succédant à jean-pierre sevestre est
démissionnaire après une période de vive
tension dans la commune la fusion
avortée avec maurepas qui a causé une
opposition citoyenne et aussi des
défections au sein de la majorité
municipale elle jean-pierre sevestre
avait lui même succédé à henri pailleux
maire depuis 1986 et qui a démissionné
en avril 2015 voilà pour le contexte le
contexte posé après plus
plus d'un an de mandat il est évident
pour vous de vouloir transformer l'essai
de continuer de continuer cette
mandature avec un mandat plus long oui
ça serait ça semble être une évidence
d'autant plus je pense pas qu'on ait
démérité
on avait un projet qui était ambitieux
mais réaliste on l'a réalisé aujourd'hui
à 80% les 20% restants en définitive
sont en cours donc on est plutôt
satisfait de cette mandature
ça veut dire cette période de tension
qui est en 2018 elle est totalement
derrière les coignard vais pas sauter de
nos promesses d'ailleurs c'était de
revenir à de la sérénité de redonner un
nouvel élan la ville et à l'action
municipale
aujourd'hui les poignées rien je
rencontre me disent que c'est gagné
d'une certaine façon c'est à dire qu'il
sent effectivement cette sérénité
aujourd'hui retrouver en ville
et puis il ya cet élan il ya ce
dynamisme qu'ils apprécient d'une
manière générale maintenant évidemment
on compte pas forcément tout le monde et
les gens qui me parlent sont peut-être
pas ceux qui s'opposent à moins et donc
voilà
et si vous faites le bilan vous disais
que 80% du bien commun 80 % du programme
qui réalisé bon je pense à la maison des
jeunes je pense à la réfection du city
stade je pense au gymnase qui est en
quête en travaux en ce moment il ya
d'autres
d'autres réalisations on a on a mis par
exemple en place un véritable service de
l'insertion professionnelle et puis à
quelque chose dont je suis content et
l'équipe aussi est contente c'est la
fameuse navette scolaire puisque nous on
a une ville quand même avec des
quartiers excentrés l'autre côté de la
nationale 10 et ça c'est très utile
aujourd'hui pour les enfants pour qu'ils
puissent se rendre dans les deux groupes
scolaires et on voit bien c'est une
réussite puisqu'on est parti on avait 22
enfants en septembre aujourd'hui on en a
45 qui sont véhiculés de cette façon là
et c'est c'est intéressant parce que je
m'en étais pas rendu compte forcément
tout de suite mais les parents me disent
ils ont gagné en autonomie et les
enfants gagnent en autonomie
nous on a gagné au niveau
environnemental aussi parce qu'on a
moins de voitures devant les écoles et
d'une façon générale c'est un vrai
service qui est rendu aujourd'hui cette
catégorie de la population
or votre liste sera une nouvelle fois
sans étiquette comme il y a un en cdd
fischer vous êtes un homme de gauche est
ce que vous vous revendiquez une
investiture est ce que vous attendez un
soutien on mange donc un soutien
revendique aucune investiture la liste
sera sans étiquette moi-même et et mes
colistiers ne sont pas encartés donc
voyez on est vraiment tout à fait libres
indépendants en quelque sorte même si
évidemment en tous les cas moi j'ai eu
un passé à gauche et je reste un homme
de gosses bien entendu d'ailleurs ça se
sont aussi dans la paix dans les
politiques que l'on aime je pense à
coignières il ya une attention très
particulière dans le domaine social
notamment
mais au sein de votre liste diverses
opinions politiques est ce que ce soit
justement avec la même équipe que vous
allez reproposer cette candidature de la
même équipe s'est dit heureux événement
effectivement il ya un fort noyau qui
sera effectivement le noyau de base de
mai qui est important ils ont l'équipe
sera renouvelée aux environs d'un tiers
à peu près aux environs d'un tiers ce
qui permet d'afficher aussi un certain
renouvellement des visages nouveaux des
gens qui veulent s'engager pour leur
commune qui veulent travailler dans
l'intérêt commun
dans l'intérêt collectif je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et il n'y avait
pas de raison aujourd'hui oui la liste
est complète j'ai même j'ai dirigé des
je suis encore en train de faire un
certain nombre de choix parce que c'est
quand même pas évident et puis j'attends
encore un peu avant de publier cette
liste mais la liste est complète oui
bien sûr votre programme plutôt vos
priorités pour la commune où vous les
avez évoqué dans une lettre adressée aux
habitants novembre dernier volet
environnement notamment vous souhaitez
que coignières intègre le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
une intégration qui pourrait être
progressive à partir de 2023 avec un
statut de ville porte pour cogneur
pourquoi pourquoi cette démarche
pourquoi vouloir intégrer le pnr je
pense que c'est important pour pour
coignières qui est une image qui n'est
pas forcément une image très bonne du
côté de l'environnement quand on voit
cette nationale 10 quand on voit ces
zones d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui
dans une situation un peu de
dégradations dans certains certains
côtés donc l'idée d'intégrer le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
c'est en fait
une façon de dire vous voyez coignières
c'est aussi un village coignières c'est
aussi 70% des terres agricoles
coignières c'est aussi aujourd'hui parmi
ces terres agricoles 70 % de terres qui
sont en bio donc on serait on serait
sûrement la commune aujourd'hui qui
aurait le plus de terre en bio si on
était intégrée au parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse et puis
quelque part c'est profiter de
l'ingénierie du parc aussi dans tous nos
comment dire dans toutes nos politiques
ça pourrait faire profiter notamment
peut-être des projets en termes de
patrimoine et aussi du patrimoine du
parti trop vite et faire classer
l'église saint germain d'auxerre voilà
c'est effectivement admis sous et ça
sera une de mes propositions
le classement où l'inscription je dirais
aux monuments historiques donc de cette
église
tout simplement parce qu'elles le
méritent c'est une église qui est une
base du 12e siècle du 12e au 19e siècle
qui a des superbes vitraux qui un
tableau site valeur à l'intérieur et
cela permet aussi de définir une zone de
protection aussi pour le vieux
coignières pour l'ancien village donc et
ça je crois les habitants sont très
attachés à la protection de leur village
autre volet c'est la culture vous voulez
doter la commune d'une politique
culturelle importante avec la mise en
place d'une direction dédiée à l'idée
c'est de donner notamment un nouveau
souffle au théâtre alphonse daudet n'y a
pas assez de quoi n'y a rien qui se
rendent aujourd'hui dans ce terrain 20%
les spectacles aujourd'hui au théâtre
d'auch des ses 20% de quoi n'y a rien là
j'ose et à 20 % se trouve que c'est
insuffisant je rencontre des gens qui me
disent
le théâtre c'est pas pour nous eh bien
si c'est pour vous c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment développer
une politique culturelle d'envergure
parce que la culture c'est pas
simplement ce petit supplément d'âme
c'est la vie et je crois qu'on a tous
besoin en effet de culture alors je veux
aussi par exemple par rapport au théâtre
y créer des activités qui sont pas
forcément des activités théâtrales par
exemple bien réparé café qui s'est
installée au théâtre ce qui fait qu'il
ya des gens qui viennent pour réparer je
ne sais pas moi un grille pain
un poste de radio et puis qu'il entre au
théâtre qui voit les affiches qui voit
les programmes qui se disent après tout
tient pourquoi pas et bah c'est gagné et
j'ai eu deux trois réflexions comme cela
de la dernière fois lors du dernier et
parcs cafés ou des gens qui m'ont des
abats finalement ça veut pas bazot
prévenir la prochaine représentation la
voyez c'est ça finalement
c'est comme cela la culture elle infuse
de cette façon là alors d'autres
priorités on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans différents reportages d'éducation
famille emploi je voulais vous faire
réagir ce que vous êtes également vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'action sociale est ce que le travail
avec la collectivité vous menez ce qu'il
est satisfaisant est ce que vous
souhaitez le renforcer avoir écouté si
on peut le renforcer le renforcera mais
moi j'ai très bonne relation se dire on
travaille en confiance avec la
collectivité avec l'agglomération
on travaille aussi sur tout ce qui est
aujourd'hui requalification urbaine
études paris ouest le comment dire le
carrefour de la madone
voilà là on travaille très bien avec les
équipes avec les équipes de soins de
saint quentin
je dirais que
c'est déjà engagées c'est à dire qu'il
ya déjà une relation qui est forte
le passé c'est le passé vous savez
comment la poigne air est entré
finalement dans la communauté
d'agglomération on n'y a été précipitée
par un arrêté du préfet bon aujourd'hui
par une décision préfectorale
aujourd'hui c'est le passé aujourd'hui
on est à saint quentin en yvelines
eh bien on va jouer on joue notre rôle
au sein de l'agglomération
dernière chose très rapidement ce
programme vous allez le co construire
avec les habitants vous organisé
d'ailleurs des ateliers thématiques
s'est organisé toute une série d'autres
dans une série d'ateliers thématiques au
jeu rendez vous avec les lots 6 janvier
où on va faire un rendu justement de ces
ateliers thématiques et on va commencer
à proposer les premiers véritables
éléments du projet merci didier fischer
je rappel merci beaucoup
la maire sortant de coignières tête de
liste aux municipales de cette
candidature sans étiquette un élan
durable pour cogner et je précise qu'une
autre liste est en course aussi pour le
moment dans la commune celle menée par
et xavier girard qui mènera la
candidature citoyenne coignières à venir
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant le retour
à l'antenne du 7-8 société la
reconnaissance faciale une technologie
qui fascine autant qu'elle inquiète
thématiques abordées ce soir belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]